hallo leute wir sind heute in berlin und
bayern sind die und lukas sie kamen von
der university of toronto in kanada und
das ist die hände von kanada
[Musik]
und so weiter wir fragen heute leute in
berlin was sie über kanada denken
los geht's
[Applaus]
was denken sie über keine da kanada hat
viel natur oder kanada denke dass da
viel wald gibt viele holzfäller sehr
entspanntes leben
was denken sie über keinen kalt sehr
kalt aber ich denke mir landschaftlich
ist keine große herausforderung ein
großes flächenland mit zweisprachigen
bevölkerung französisch und englisch
also ich bin keine raten total tolle
plant ich war ein jahr im ausland dort
und habe sehr genau das hat mir sehr
gefallen ist superschön ort ich mag den
premierminister
er wirkt er sympathisch schönes land
viel natur
ich war vor jahren in kanada im dienste
hin und habe dort kanada besucht und
habe kein zweites land mit einer tollen
wolken landschaft die wollten sehr hoch
über keinerlei hinwegziehen
und das war sehr abend und das hat mir
sehr gefallen kanada ist ein
wunderschönes land ich war da vor 30
jahren
wenn ich den mut gehabt hätte zum
auswandern dass er mein land sehr
schönes land sehr viel natur würden wir
gerne mal hin form also was ich in
erinnerung habe ewig lange straßen durch
wälder 1000 wirken um einen herum
man hofft dass man werden sie uns nicht
kein aber hat mir gut gefallen hätte
leute aber war wunderschön wir vier
wochen mit dem wohnmobil durchs land
gezogen
es war herrlich also ich würde es wieder
machen aber mein mann haben sehr gehört
damit der bagger dahin was erzählt man
sich über kanada riesige landschaften
schöne natur nette menschen
der bus stereotypen gibt es schon wieder
so dass bern gibt und was aber es ist
eigentlich nicht so in die leute sind
sehr nett
einfach sehr offen sehr nett und immer
würfel ein da sehr freundlich waffen
bild hat man in deutschland von kanada
ich glaube ein ganz entspanntes ja auch
politisch entspannt ins jahr wandert
durch die usa
glaube ich ja einfach durch den
präsident natürlich wahrnehmen erzeugen
ist herr trio in kanada glaube ich ein
junger dynamischer aber sehr positiver
mensch und deswegen ich glaube das ist
nur das bild was man vielleicht
wahrnimmt ja das glaube ich toleranz ist
politisch ein was bekannt ist also dass
man demokratie hat demokratische regeln
und dass man sich als bevölkerung falsch
miteinander vereinbart
und was sind die die unterschiede
zwischen deutschland und kanada
naja deutschland ist in europa und
deutschland hat eine europäische kultur
kann ehrlich genug amerika da sind sehr
viele einwanderer gekommen und somit ist
auch natürlich die natur und die kultur
eine andere
und so stellt sich das auch dann den in
der gesellschaft nach glaubt kanadier
sind deutlich gezählt acht deutschen
westteils und dort alles was wir
entspannen ist das schön
ich denke die leute sind freundlich ja
dieses eine ziel was ist zb gibt die
leute in kanada wenn sie aus dem bus
aussteigen lassen sich bedanken bei dem
busfahrer
hier freut man sich bei der busfahrer
einrichtung an bord haben sie etwas
negatives schon über kanada gehört nein
eigentlich nicht
kanada ist ein land mit zwei sprachen
einmal französisch einmal englisch und
genau da gibt es manchmal schon
differenzen nun spannungen auf einem
großen und ganzen ist kann das schon ein
sehr demokratisches und weltoffenes land
haben
negativ da denke ich noch gar nicht
bisher berichten alle freunde die in
toronto war sehr positiv
noch nie hat nur nicht sein schon früher
her nicht das spannend dass ich meine
theorie nicht aufgestellt habe das eben
wenn negatives passiert nimmt man es in
deutschland gar nicht wahr
und wenn es jetzt passiert ist gefeiert
häufig nicht also ich glaube dass
negative wenn wir gerade mit der
veränderung der usa dass das schon
wahrgenommen wird
aber mir ist jetzt persönlich nicht
bekannt was ich mit kanada und mit einem
negativen momente verbindet ich habe
auch immer noch dass die leute im netz
so das klischee am forggensee von kanada
an songs negatives eigentlich nicht ich
glaube wirklich über canaria gibt es
kaum schlechte negative vorurteile oder
denken dabei spielt in der deutschen
großen öffentlichkeit eine
untergeordnete rolle für nach meiner
erfahrung ist es eigentlich kein thema
in deutschland
leider vielleicht wären wir ja noch
nichts negatives über kanada gehört es
gibt so einen mythos in deutschland dass
alles gut ist
stimmt das so weil es kann sehr kalt
sein in gewinnt 50 oder 70 sein 50
probleme probleme und kann jetzt auch an
viele soziale probleme
zum beispiel die behandlung befand
umgang mit pferden der ureinwohner una
donna jaguar ureinwohnern hat man in
deutschland nichts man denkt dass er ein
super gerechtes land seit wo es keine
sozialen probleme gibt und mit
einwanderung läuft alles super
das ist nicht so vielleicht ist zugleich
fahne die usa denn schon friedrich und
ja so freundlich oder etwas aber wenn du
genau so wirklich eng kann egal ist
dann erlebt so etwas genau also ihr seid
ihr seid schon ein fortschrittliches
land aber perfekt ist trotzdem nicht
alles lukas stimmte zu
ja ich stimme dazu das war unser video
über kenne da wir haben nichts negatives
gehört über kanada kanada
wenn ihr noch betreuen möchte zu diesem
video dann werdet ein kätzchen und wenn
ihr mehr wie wir ziehen möchte dann
abonniert unseren kanal sitz und bis zum
nächsten mal
abonniert und werdet einen patch 1